well after a film as 90s as a goofy
movie we can go even more nineties
easier with an extremely goofy movie yep
because everything in the 90s was a
chance surprise I didn't tell this with
an axe because well we'll get to that in
a minute I guess in a sense this is
exactly what I think of when I hear
direct-to-dvd sequels or at least what I
thought they were going to be before
they started doing the big popular
movies goofy movie was a modest success
and it did pretty well on VHS so I kind
of figure to do a direct-to-dvd movie
that's just kind of what they did back
then and honestly you get what you'd
expect and will be like this would offer
it opens with Max and his friends
getting ready to go off to college
goofy once again is having a hard time
as a loving parent letting go of his kid
to its credit well is cramming a lot of
cool stuff at the time in your face it
does take some time to actually be a
little emotional II considerate but
things go south when goofy is fired from
his job and has to find another one he's
told that the majority of jobs require
college degrees nowadays so enter
exactly what you think is going to
happen goofy goes to college with max
and under pretty much every other thing
you think is going to happen max enters
the competitive sports there's a bully
that makes fun of them that preppy
cheaters who make fun of the fact that
father is there who of course make
things worse Max's embarrass their
relationship is pulled apart again and
of course it ends with some sort of big
sports event oh did I say some sort of
event like I forgot what it was no no I
remember you couldn't forget for the
life of you it's the X Games because
they found it the hell into you it's
beyond obvious that Disney owned ESPN
because they plaster that everywhere to
Max's whole goal in this thing is to
enter the X Games and win it it's so
weird to see that logo without some sort
of parody or satire in there but no it's
all just one obvious commercial it's
really weird
so okay the story is about recycled as
it can get is there anything good in it
yeah there's a couple things like I said
there's one or two emotional moments
that are free but the fact I feel like
the animation is trying to be funnier
than it's allowed like the bully
character he's animated funny he's
voiced by a funny voice actor but
just not given any dialogue or scenes
they're very funny but at the same time
look at him you kind of want to laugh at
them a little bit goofy also starts a
bit of a romance with this librarian
who's also low Corky and awkward and
again look at oh she's animated no kind
of wild laughter but the key word is
want as in they want you to laugh they
want to get reaction out of you but
there's just not that much substance
there some things that don't even get
like max and the bullies are in this
beatnik coffeehouse which don't even
exist anymore
I mean know there's coffee houses but
these people look like they're out of 50
not a 90 and they all start snapping
that for some reason scares the bullies
away I don't get it this whole movie
feels like a really good joke being set
up but for whatever reason we never
quite get the punchline it kind of holds
back it never becomes anything it just
sort of falls into that mesh of typical
college movies except now for kids
health it does inspire monsters you know
I'm so thankful for that I don't think
these are as entertaining as Disney
thinks they are it just kind of feels
like opportunities they're never fully
taken advantage of and speaking of which
I'm just going to say it
I miss Roxanne I mean I know high school
going to different colleges
puppy love separation all that stuff but
I'm sorry they were a really cute couple
could the movie have been about that
maybe about them breaking up or deciding
whether or not they wanted to stay
together or going to different school
you know actual interesting stuff stuff
that some kids may need to know when
going to college but nope it's all about
being the sports star and trying not to
be embarrassed by your wacky parents ah
I see this only if you're a die-hard
goof troop fan or I don't know an
example of them will be trying to save
itself despite a bad script but now that
interests you it's exactly what you
think of directed DVD movies going to be
take it for what's worth and see the X
Games yourself I mean extremely goofy
movie yourself capture the tie-in
you
[Music]